- As you may have heard,
we are in a bit of a housing
crisis here in America.
Median home prices and rental rates
have been skyrocketing
across much of the country.
If you happen to already own a home,
congrats! You've probably seen
your equity get a good bump
in the last few years.
- But if you're like the
millions of Americans who rent
or are trying to get
into the housing market,
this, for lack of a better word, sucks.
- This surge in home prices,
as we explained in an earlier video,
is mainly the result of
having too few homes for sale.
New construction never really recovered
from the 2008 market collapse.
And that, coupled with strict zoning laws
and pandemic-fueled shortages
of supplies and labor,
has created a drastic housing shortage.
- But this problem is exacerbated
by the unprecedented rise
in real estate speculation.
The housing market is so hot
that it's attracting investors
across the economic spectrum,
from mom and pop landlords,
to huge private equity firms,
It's driving prices even higher
and making it harder for ordinary families
to get in the game.
(upbeat music)
- The last time we had a housing
boom, it didn't end well.
The bubble burst in 2008,
largely because of subprime mortgages,
poorly structured loans
given out by reckless lenders
to borrowers who could not afford them.
But recent findings suggest
that real estate investors
played a greater role than
previously understood.
- According to a study by
three professors of finance,
areas that had a lot
of housing speculation
saw prices climb higher during the boom
and plummet lower during the bust.
This had a ripple effect
throughout the economy.
Unemployment, wage stagnation,
even closures of local businesses
were all worse in areas
that had a high level
of housing speculation.
- To be clear, real estate investment
did not cause the Great Recession,
but it seems to have
exacerbated the damage.
"In the absence of speculation,
the size of the boom and bust
would have been about a third smaller,"
said one author of the study.
- Why did this happen?
Well, if a lot of speculators
descend on a certain area,
there are fewer houses to go around,
which drives up prices,
but no one's actually
living in these houses.
So when the market turns south,
you end up with too much
inventory, pushing prices lower.
- Though the speculators
didn't see this coming,
some financiers did.
A handful of savvy investors
predicted the housing crash
and made a ton of money
betting against the market
in a move that's come to
be known as the Big Short.
One of the most prominent of them
was a Goldman Sachs executive
named Donald Mullen,
who right after the crash
pivoted to becoming a speculator himself.
- Mullen started an investment
firm called Pretium Partners,
which raised over a billion
dollars from foreign investors
to buy up foreclosed homes across America
and turn them into rental units.
Today, Pretium is the largest owner
of single family homes in the country,
and a lot of other mega corporations
are following their lead.
- In the competition for limited housing,
these firms enjoy several
massive advantages.
The average American home buyer
will have to find a listing,
visit the property,
negotiate with the owner,
put in an offer, and secure
a mortgage from a bank,
all before a sale can be made.
If you've ever bought a house,
you know it can take a while.
- But giant real estate firms like Pretium
have sophisticated algorithms
that can scan the market
for the best deals
and automatically make a cash offer
within hours of the listing.
The ease and speed of the transaction
is so attractive to sellers,
they're even willing to take less money.
Researchers estimate that
investors like Pretium
actually pay around 10% less
than individual home buyers,
thanks to this advantage.
- They tend to target
majority black neighborhoods
at a rate almost three times
higher than other zip codes.
Why?
It may be because their
algorithms perceive these houses
as artificially undervalued.
In other words, prejudice
keeps prices lower
than what they should be.
If the neighborhood can be gentrified,
there's a potential for
a larger profit margin.
- Pretium's property
management subsidiary,
Progress Residential,
doesn't have many satisfied customers.
Families that rent from them
complain about the shoddy maintenance
and ever-increasing rents and fees,
and they are far more
aggressive about evictions
than mom and pop landlords.
One housing advocate
called their standard lease
"about as punitive as we've seen..."
- Defenders of such corporate landlords
argue that they offer single
family residence living
to many people who'd otherwise
never be able to achieve it.
They also claim that private equity firms
buying up foreclosed homes
is what helped the housing
market recover from the collapse.
And does it really matter
whether a family is
paying rent or a mortgage?
After all, "the reality is
most people don't own a home.
They rent the home from the bank.
From the outside, it
really looks the same."
- That quote was said by Pretium's
head of real estate, Dana Hamilton,
who is definitely smart enough
to know the enormous difference
between renting and owning: equity.
For 80 years, home ownership
has been the number one way
for ordinary Americans
to save for the future
and start creating generational wealth.
- That's what makes real estate attractive
to firms like Pretium,
which is why some housing advocates
call their business
practice equity-mining,
stripping neighborhoods of the
pool of investment potential
that used to be accessible
to the general population.
- Well, there are other ways
to build equity, you might say.
In fact, the stock market has
seen overall better returns
than real estate over the last 80 years.
True, but you can't
live in your portfolio.
A house is that rare kind of purchase
that doubles as an
investment and a shelter.
- Also, mortgages offer far better terms
than personal loans.
No bank is gonna give you
$200,000 at 4% interest
so you can go buy a bunch of stock.
They'd get a better return just
buying the stock themselves.
The government deliberately
started the mortgage program
to offer ordinary people
the chance to build equity.
It's widely credited with
creating the middle class,
and the tacit exclusion of
black Americans from the program
is why today they suffer
from a vast discrepancy
in generational wealth.
- Now, we are not saying
there's anything wrong
with investing in real estate.
In fact, we've often recommended it
as a reliable way to grow your money,
but we're not talking about someone
taking out a loan to buy a rental property
to save for retirement.
This is a corporate-backed
takeover of America's suburbs
at a time when housing is in short supply.
- The government could try
to discourage the trend through taxation,
but rent is not considered capital gains.
And companies like Pretium are
run through offshore havens,
protecting them from most U.S. taxes.
At the end of the day,
the government can't really tell someone
who they can or can't sell their house to.
- Many housing advocates concede
that the most hopeful path
to making home ownership accessible again
is to simply build more houses and fast.
Increasing the inventory
of available homes
will lower prices
and make the market less
attractive to speculators.
Many states are currently
changing their zoning
laws to speed this up.
- In the meantime, if you're
one of the unfortunate buyers
competing with mega firms,
don't get discouraged.
It may take more time and effort,
but owning a home is still worth it.
And unlike the last price increase,
we're far less likely to
see a massive bubble burst
that will leave homeowners
holding the bag.
- Also, renting doesn't have
to be a dead-end street.
As we've explained in a previous video,
there are some advantages,
as long as you find other ways
to build equity and save money,
so you can possibly have a down payment
when you're ready to
enter the housing market.
- [Both] And that's our two cents.
- If you're worried about
being stuck renting,
you might wanna check out our
video, "Is It Okay to Rent?".
(upbeat music)